this program is brought to you by Emory
University
so a few lessons one is that HIV remains
and will remain a very important and
very difficult public health problem
locally and globally there will be no
simple solution even a vaccine or cure
would not result in a simple solution I
think about it if you could say well we
now have a cure we only have to reach
the 30 million people infected in the
world before they affect everybody else
and then we have to deliver it to them
or the safe and effective vaccine that's
a hundred percent effective in
transmitting the virus so we only have
six and a half billion people to give
the vaccine to so we have a lot of
issues now I can't think of anything
better than a cure or vaccine and I
can't think of anything better than
joining the army to try to accomplish
these things but I think we can say that
we're going to need commitment for the
rest of our lives to deal with this
problem and that there will be continued
breakthroughs to help us the preceding
program is copyrighted by emory
university